vamos a decir que queremos averiguar el
equilibrio constante de la reacción de
fluoruro de boro
y déjame ponerlo aquí el fluoruro de
boro de boro y lo voy a tener en estado
gaseoso ok ya esto le voy a sumar 3
veces 3 moles por cada muerte este vamos
a tener a más 3 moles de agua de h2o en
estado líquido ok vamos a ponerlo en
estado líquido y esto está en equilibrio
esto está en equilibrio y por lo tanto
vamos hacia adelante y también vamos
hacia atrás ok y esto nos da 3 moles de
ácido fluorhídrico ambite que ponerlo
con otro color con este color voy a
poner 3 moles de ácido fluorhídrico en y
está disuelto en el agua así que vamos a
decir que está en estado agua
ok ojo si no se disolvió en el agua y
está en estado sólido podríamos llamarlo
fluoruro de hidrógeno una vez que esto
está disuelto en el agua lo llamamos
ácido fluorhídrico y bueno ya veremos
más adelante cómo se nombran todos estos
compuestos pero a esto le voy a sumar y
déjeme ponerlo con otro color
le voy a sumar ok un mole de ácido
bórico también en estado agosto a h3 y
h3t o 3 también esto está en estado
acuoso ok tengo esta reacción en
equilibrio constante así que recordemos
un poco cuál sería la expresión para el
equilibrio constante vista en esta
situación podría estar tentado a decir
ok esto es suficientemente fácil sal
para el equilibrio constante solamente
necesitas tomar el equilibrio constante
ok
sólo tomamos el lado derecho de esta
ecuación
bueno ojo esto es por convención podría
reescribir lo porque hay una simetría
justo aquí y entonces lo podemos
escribir de ambos modos y ojo también
sería correcto pero sólo vamos a decir
que tomamos primero el lado derecho por
convención y dices ok esto es
dependiente de la concentración del
ácido fluorhídrico y déjame ponerlo así
a la concentración del ácido
fluorhídrico o la modalidad del ácido
fluorhídrico elevado a la tercera
potencia a la tercera potencia por la
concentración de este de aquí por la
concentración déjame ponerlo así del
ácido bórico es decir h3 y h3t o 3 ok
y ojo recuerda que esta intuición de por
qué estás tomando esta potencia 3 es
cuál es la probabilidad porque estamos
hablando de que este es el orden para
que la reacción vaya por este camino
necesitas tener tres moléculas de ácido
fluorhídrico está
muy cerca de una molécula de ácido
bórico entonces si ves el vídeo pasado
que acabo de hacer sobre la intuición
detrás del equilibrio constante esto es
indicativo de la probabilidad de que
esta reacción ocurra o la probabilidad
de encontrar todas estas moléculas en el
mismo lugar por supuesto puedes ajustar
esto con una constante y esto es
esencialmente lo que se hace pero bueno
esto está en el lado del producto o del
reactivo dependiendo de en qué dirección
estás viendo la ecuación esto lo vamos a
dividir todo esto lo vamos a dividir
entre la polaridad o la concentración
del tri fluoruro de borón del tri
fluoruro de boro ok
3 ok y esto x am y déjenme cambiar de
color por la polaridad la polaridad del
agua ok del h2o esto elevado a la
tercera potencia y por supuesto el h2o
en estado líquido así que aquí lo tienes
nos limitaremos a resolver solo esto mi
refutación para ti es que quiero que
averigües la polaridad del agua cual es
la concentración del agua y bueno
recuerda que la concentración es moles
por volumen pero en este caso que está
pasando estoy poniendo un poco de gas
del tri fluoruro de borón esencialmente
en algo de agua y está creando estos
ácidos acuosos que tengo aquí estas
otras moléculas están completamente
disueltas en el agua entonces cuál es el
solvente aquí bueno pues el solvente
solvente es el agua el solvente
el agua h2o eso quiere decir que el agua
está en donde sea el agua es el
excedente
así que si quisieras obtener la
concentración del agua bueno pues el
agua está en todas partes y si piensas
sobre esto a partir del punto de vista
de la probabilidad y dices ok para que
esta reacción directa suceda necesito
descifrar la probabilidad de encontrar
una molécula del tri fluoruro de boro en
un cierto volumen y esto también
necesita tres moles de agua en ese mismo
volumen pero puedes decir hey hay agua
en todas partes
este es el solvente así que realmente
necesito preocuparme sobre la
concentración del tri fluoruro de boro y
entonces yo escribo con este color la
velocidad de la reacción a la velocidad
de la reacción directa bueno pues esto
va a depender de una constante de una
constante de la reacción directa por la
concentración del tri fluoruro de boro
efe 3 y solamente por esta concentración
porque el agua está en todas partes así
que no tienes que multiplicar esto por
la concentración del agua lo que sea que
signifique porque el agua está en todas
partes y bueno si ahora pensamos esto en
el denominador de aquí no debemos de
poner al solvente no debemos de poner al
solvente y esta es la respuesta correcta
es decir poner únicamente lo que está
actualmente disuelto en la solución
porque francamente la concentración no
tiene sentido para todos los demás y si
piensa sobre esto desde el punto de
vista de probabilidad esto también tiene
mucho sentido porque siempre hay agua
alrededor si dice ok cuál es la
probabilidad de encontrar agua en
cualquier volumen pequeño de nuestro
fluido va a ser 1 así que puedes
simplemente multiplicar esto por 1 pero
si te das cuenta esto no hace diferencia
muy bien y ahora qué va a pasar con la
siguiente reacción y para eso déjame
subir un poco en la pantalla porque
vamos a hablar
de la siguiente reacción imagínate que
ahora tengo
a un equilibrio en donde tenemos
diferentes estados de la materia ya eso
se le conoce como un equilibrio
heterogéneo así que tenemos escribirlo
aquí equilibrio equilibrio heterogéneo
t
pero genio
y lleva siendo justo aquí y además
déjame ponerte un ejemplo de este tipo
de equilibrio heterogéneo qué te parece
si nosotros nos tomamos agua h2o pero en
estado gaseoso y bueno si te das cuenta
esto esencialmente es vapor de agua así
que esto no va a ser el solvente en esta
ocasión ya esto le voy a agregar un
carbono ok en estado sólido aquí date
cuenta que ya tenemos dos estados la
materia y vamos a decir que esto está en
equilibrio en equilibrio heterogéneo con
a mí se me ocurre pensar en hidrógeno en
estado gaseoso en h2 en estado gaseoso
más monóxido de carbono monóxido de
carbono también está en estado gaseoso
esto es un equilibrio heterogéneo porque
tienes cosas en estado gaseoso y sólido
por otro lado el estado sólido por
definición no se puede disolver ya sea
en un gas o en una solución
cuando hablamos de soluciones ojo antes
hablábamos de coloides suspensiones
pero actualmente estamos hablando de
soluciones y por definición si esto está
en estado sólido no se disuelve si esto
estuviera disuelto escribiríamos un
acoso justo aquí es decir estaría en
estado a post
entonces se habla sobre la reacción
directa de que va a depender esta
reacción directa y bueno pensemos un
poco en anti tema cambie de color en la
velocidad en la velocidad de la reacción
directa y bueno lo primero que quiero
que te des cuenta es que aquí tenemos
carbono en estado sólido es más podemos
pensar en un cubo de carbono y déjame
ponerlo con este color podría pensar en
un cubo así ok de carbono más o menos
así ok
aquí tengo mi cubo de carbono y si te
das cuenta aquí tengo h2o en vapor así
que vamos a poner aquí un buen de
partículas de gas de agua
y justo así estas están alrededor del
cubo de carbono
así que si eliges cualquier volumen
especialmente si escoges a algún volumen
cerca de los límites aquí de este sólido
de carbono entonces siempre vas a tener
carbono alrededor aquí justo lo que
importa es la concentración del gas de
agua esto nos va a conducir a pensar que
la velocidad directa a la podemos ver de
la siguiente manera esto es exactamente
lo mismo que una constante directa la
constante que siempre hemos hablado por
la concentración del gas de agua por la
concentración del gas de agua y claro la
velocidad hacia atrás es decir si
pensamos en el sentido inverso y es más
lo podemos ver aquí si nosotros tomamos
a algunas moléculas de agua déjame poner
aquí una molécula de agua se va a ver
más o menos así más o menos así aquí
tengo una molécula de agua y déjame
dibujar por acá otras moléculas de
monóxido de carbono
imagínate que aquí tengo una molécula
y monóxido de carbono algo más o menos
así ok y si te das cuenta la velocidad
de la reacción inversa va a ser igual y
déjame ponerlo así la velocidad de la
reacción inversa esto va a ser igual
alguna constante por la probabilidad de
encontrar ambas de estas moléculas en el
mismo lugar y por supuesto la
probabilidad está relacionada o está en
una aproximación de primer nivel
dependiendo de la concentración así que
es la concentración del h2 ok la
concentración del hidrógeno por la
concentración del monóxido de carbono ok
justo esto entonces cuando una reacción
está en equilibrio estas dos son iguales
la una a la otra
estas dos y justo me falta una y de
inversa por aquí ok y vamos a hacer
estas dos iguales y entonces antes de
atrapar esta herramienta y voy a copiar
esta parte de aquí ok vamos a copiar y
pegar ok esto me va a servir justo por
aquí ya
y lo voy a hacer igual pongámoslo con
esta herramienta lo voy a hacer igual a
esta otra parte que tengo aquí así que
también la voy a seleccionar ok y la voy
a copiar y la voy a pegar ok la voy a
hacer igual a esta parte de aquí ahora
si dividimos todo esto primero entre caí
y después entre la concentración del
agua que voy a obtener bueno pues que
cadena y déjame ponerlo con este color
aunque acá de ok entre entre hamaca
y déjame ponerlo con ese mismo color
entre acá y es decir las constantes esto
es exactamente igual que esta parte de
aquí y para eso déjenme atrapar esta
parte de aquí ok la voy a atrapar y la
voy a copiar y la voy a pegar ok
esta parte de aquí aunque a su vez está
dividida que a su vez está dividida
entre a la concentración del agua que es
esto de aquí entre la concentración del
agua
ahora si yo quito estas dos de aquí ya
esto le pongo el nombre de la constante
de equilibrio la constante de equilibrio
entonces puede obtener justo esta
expresión que tengo aquí recuerda que
esto es porque tenemos dos constantes
arbitrarias así que necesitamos llamarlo
equilibrio constante y bueno lo que
quiero que veas es que en realidad tiene
mucho sentido el ignorar el estado
sólido en el equilibrio de la reacción y
bueno para concluir este vídeo si yo
subo un poco más la pantalla lo que
quiero que veas es lo siguiente en el
primer caso lo que nosotros hicimos fue
en ese caso del tri fluoruro de boro y
del agua lo que hicimos fue ignorar y
déjame cambiar de color ignorar ignorar
ignorar ok el sol 20 el sol 20 ahora en
el segundo caso justo este que tenemos
aquí del carbono sólido lo que hicimos
fue ignorar
el sólido ignorar el sólido hablando de
nuestra constante de equilibrio sólido
ok y bueno de todos modos probablemente
usaremos esto en cosas futuras donde de
hecho calcularemos el equilibrio
constante nos vemos en el próximo vídeo
donde vamos a aprender sobre el
principio de ley a teller